this is a production of Cornell
University
we work a lot with mortality we work a
lot with composting with organic matter
at the waste management institute and in
this last year how many people knew that
we had an avian influenza outbreak in
the United States so quite a few people
if you listening to NPR they did have it
on NPR they had it on some other places
it was in some publications but it
wasn't out there that that vastly 50
million birds were affected west of the
Mississippi so we didn't get it in the
East at all so we didn't have to deal
with it in the East but we were
commissioned to deal with it in the West
so or from west of the Mississippi so we
did lose 50 million birds or 50 million
birds had to be either killed or they
died of the disease they don't die of
the disease right away some when we came
on to cite would be dead but there would
be some half dead and there'd be some
alive and their be you know all
different ones so it was interesting
what we ready we work with we've for the
last twelve 12 13 14 years we've been
working with avis so animal Plant Health
Inspection Service and we work with them
in Washington DC so we're working with
them and we work with them on mortality
issues because when we have a disease
outbreak we need to be dealing with that
disease and we're going to have a lot of
carcasses to get rid of we don't have a
lot of options to get rid of these
carcasses so they often times lay around
and when there's a disease outbreak they
can't lay around so this year last year
was the first time push came to shove
actually it was to your January last
year push came to shove and they said we
need to get these birds dealt with and
we need to get them into we need to
compost them
a lot of the poultry farms felt that
they were going to be able to just land
fill them and the landfills would take
them or they be able to bury them and in
most cases that was not the case some
things did go to landfill and we'll talk
about those but for the most part the
land pills don't want because people the
people that work in the landfills may
there's fear that they may be exposed to
the diseases it's not a disease that has
jumped to humans at this point but it's
still disease that's airborne and and
can move around and fear is there so the
landfills won't take them in there all
private landfill so they don't and they
don't have to take them nobody can say
you have to take them so they're there
one very very large farm with millions
of birds I think it was a genio farm
right the jennie-o farm in Iowa which
was a center fresh not her do but one of
the big ones that we'd recognize the
name they just got those big mogul the
foldable dumpsters that they say just
put all your stuff in and we'll take it
away you know so they got those and
thought that they were going to get rid
of them that way and weren't able to so
we come on to the farms I got a call I
was the first one out in the United
States so I got a call from a fish on a
saturday night saying can you go to
California and I happen to be in utah
writing Mary and I were writing
curriculum in Utah and I said well I
guess so so the next week I went out to
food in modesto went into California and
and met with the first farm so I talked
to the farms quite a bit before I went
in because you have farm managers and
you have farm owners and the farm owners
are very
they are the ones that are financing
these things so they don't know very
much about what's going on but they want
to have control so we went out we
provided them with educational materials
beforehand so that they had an idea of
what we were going to do and one of the
things that we need for these to compost
is carbon we have to have carbon on the
farms we can't just pile up birds and
expect them to degrade and in this
situation we really needed to sanitize
and that's what we're there to do not to
make compost we're there to sanitize and
kill the virus in the birds so we
provided them with information so that
they knew what was going on we tried to
get carbon to the sites before we got
there because all we're doing we're not
actually yes we were physically moving
birds and things like that but but we're
not there to were there to direct
operations to let them know how to do it
and then to make sure that it's working
properly once they do that speaking with
a the managers they've had a huge loss
you know if you can imagine losing
millions of birds on one farm they're
affected mentally emotionally we have to
think about that as well and so that was
one thing that we had to go on the farm
and say okay we understand where you are
we understand that it's really important
to you and we need to deal with this
whole situation before we could go in we
needed to have full PPE so there are
disconnects on who wears what actually
so this is what I was wearing you know
this is the type of stuff that I was
wearing I had full PPE I had you know I
didn't have glasses at first but I had
everything else breathing apparatus all
that kind of stuff the farm this is the
farmer up here had a medical gown on so
that's what the health department
provided them with so they said can we
get some PPE some protection for
ourselves and that's what they ended up
with so there's a real difference there
this is provided by a fith when we get
there it's you know we're getting
dressed and taping everything doing all
that kind of stuff and farm themselves
the farmers themselves don't how to
access to that until they get there so
the Health Department kind of gave them
a raw deal in this case this is actually
was in South Dakota and I'm going to
turn it over to Mary stand here so I can
pick up well I think you can pick me up
without first standing right here okay
cool so she was talking about the
importance of assessment and knowing
what you're walking into and when i got
to wisconsin in april of 2015 this is
what I walked into not at all what I was
expecting I had received some
information from a fost about the size
of the houses and how many birds and I'm
thinking my stuff we've been doing a lot
we've done a lot of birds before you
know I know how to compost and I'm
thinking okay no big deal we'll take the
litter you know will spread it out on
the ground will throw the birds on top
with carbon ion and we're all good yeah
not at all so so we get there and this
is
this is on a farm that has a it's called
cage-free layers okay there are 3
humvees alleyways in each House okay
their page free because they're free to
fly around all right this thing is 370
feet long these are the ways are three
feet wide okay there's only a door here
one door one door one door and in front
there's a small like 6 x 10 space that
you could maybe weíll something in okay
I'm thinking myself who on earth are we
kidding all these dead birds out of
there now this guy's got five houses
okay with three of these in each of
those houses all our 370 feet long with
one door in this particular house this
is the first house there was forty four
thousand birds they were all dead when I
got there ok I got there on a monday for
the ones up on top no he's actually that
one's still dead okay I got the round of
Monday's I think they had died on
Thursday okay now and this is from the
disease okay now luckily they kept it
cool in there so they weren't totally
liquefying I mean they were they were
starting to liquefy but they didn't
smell terrible they were still there was
still some some stuff there okay it
wasn't just just a liquid matte the
savvy barn the second house had about
80% bed 28,000 purse the other three
houses that had about I don't know 35
thousand each
there might have been ten percent debt
so it hadn't spread okay it probably
wasn't going to because we're talking
for days in between so probably wasn't
going to spread any further so now we
gotta kill those other three houses look
we gotta kill for twenty percent and
in-house to that haven't been that what
didn't die of the disease and on top of
it you can't foam in here but you get
birds flying up here okay and if you
follow me I'll show you some bow me
later if you go home you're only get in
here unless you can fill that whole
house up and then you're in real trouble
because everything's soaking wet you
ruined your equipment and your birds are
just you know bonus or something right
there but with chicken that's how it
happens yeah this is my hair okay and
was my first time dealing with an
emergency situation luckily I had the
people that I got in contact with as
soon as I got there were well prepared
you know they said texted me that gave
me a person who knew her crap knew her
chickens do something she was very smart
and you know we got all the PPE and
everything like that so everything was
good this is the proud of that that far
this is all of the equipment okay so you
know we're trying to figure out how to
get the birds out we're trying to figure
out where we're going to compost because
we can't compose you in the barn cuz
there's no space for it okay they're
talking about sending the workers down
like they would collect eggs in their
dust mask not even a might even try
decorator in their dust mask and walking
down through the 370 feet you know to
pull that chickens it can have to push a
cart clear away pull them back out you
know and I might know who that is
definitely not having any back wahap
hazard that's just not happening we'll
figure something else out so this is
your lips what we figured out okay this
is an exercise I should tell you that i
was there from a Monday through a Friday
okay we still had not started composting
at that point we did build a test i'll
which i'll show you so that i could
teach them how to compost but now we're
talking those birds have been dead a
week the other birds still haven't been
held the ones that are dying our
liquefying are getting bad but so as
they're waiting this is what end and I
apologize for the ferry's sideways but
it was taken bad boys on an iphone so oh
ok
just cook there we go so this was that
manure belt and they push the birds down
onto the felt and they came down into
the manure system and then came out here
because they had a manure system that
went from each bar to to the compost
this is a compost bar and a cup where he
was composting manure and that's where
we ended up building our first few pubs
okay so using ingenuity and whatever
they had on hand until they did finally
contract with a company to come in and
suck the dead birds out with a big
vacuum okay to get the Deford but then
they had more trouble with D populations
and they ended up having to suck out
portions at a time and then use a
garbage can co2 killer which I was not
part of did not see I'm glad I didn't
I've heard it with the fiasco
that's you know you make do with what
you have so they should probably have
had the other one first because this is
a layer when we have post birds smaller
especially Birds we can't do it the way
genes going to show you with the turkeys
we need to have a bed of carbon okay and
then you put the dead birds layer the
dead birds and their manure on top of it
and then cover with more carbon and then
we filled in layers and we have back
there some factions yep claim to
actually see the process this was the
first windrow that eventually anyway
right here on this little corner you can
see something that's raised up that was
the test window which is in the next
slide the Becky and I built before I
left to show her how to do it and then
they continue down with the base
ended up with three inside but there
were so many birds that ended up with
maybe 12 more outside and we had to get
they had to get permission from the
department of natural resources as to
where they could put those piles so that
took some time you know a lot of
rigmarole if you have the map to see
where there might be hydrologically
sensitive soil or whatever so that you
could get approval to put these windows
outside there was a lot of stuff that we
had to go through and in addition this
farm had 200,000 dozen eggs that also
needed to be taken care of they were all
in cold storage eggs as you all know our
round and they roll right so if we try
to put all those eggs each you these
compost piles hole they would roll out
plus you're cold and we're deming
they're cold you don't want to put a
whole bunch of cold stuff which team
will talk about later too in your
compost process we're trying to create
heat because he is what kills the virus
so and the other problem with him was
they were getting flats that hold two
and a half dozen some of them were
cardboard which is fine we could come
somewhat more plastic so to compost
those eggs which a lot of farms did end
up composting their eggs we chose not to
we were able to take all of those eggs
you know on a pork on pork put them into
a big truck deliver them to the landfill
okay that was a lot easier but you do if
we were going to compost him we would
have had to show them all out of their
containers break them somehow and then
add them to the windrow as we were
building so that was just not something
that was going to happen we did add beef
they had just got me new feed for the
birds just before this hit and of course
very little of it was eaten because the
urge we're dying so we have to empty out
their all their feet drop 50 silos and
put that into the pile and you have to
remember that all of the things that
could possibly be contaminated when you
take care of these so this is the
teaching pile okay and this shows two
separate layers of it what we did
because I really wanted them to do this
right was we built a two-foot base which
is
what we recommend what whoopsie wmi
recommends some people would use less
but I know my two feet is probably
different than your two feet so what we
did was we build the two-foot base and
then we put sticks in to leave two foot
clearance all around and make them put
the birds in that clearance and then we
move the sticks up and made the sticks
were like to beat and you made them feel
that well they were said that was then
you have a one-foot layer between we
made them filled up with the carbon to
one foot I don't know if they did that
too while all of the compost piles but I
wanted to make sure that at least the
the teaching pile was done properly so
that they would get adequate
temperatures and get adequate
microbiological my clothes would do
there there were now these birds
remember these birds were but we go well
that couldn't we go about five dates
dead six days dead when we built this
pile okay and within three days so they
were cold you know they weren't hot
anymore within three days we had
temperatures of 130 because
okay and and that had a lot to do with
the amount of basement clearance in the
addition of the carbon and I think well
these are some of her outdoor wind grows
to these others these years okay my lad
jingo so all in all we really wanted to
make sure that we were composting
indoors as much as possible that is the
rule always compost indoors we don't
want to liberate the virus the virus can
be spread on the air that bio eros eros
Eliza's and leaves the house so it goes
out through fans fans are always on in
those houses and it's hot enough that
they can't allow us to work in there
without the fans on so it depending on
the time of year but but at this time
and this was April it still was too hot
they really needed to have the fans on
there's there's another I won't go into
that right now so these are out just
outdoor windows this is how they some of
them like with Mary situation where they
might not have had enough outdoor indoor
space to do the composting we've got to
move them out and we want to move these
birds and the eggs and the feed and all
that kind of stuff as little as possible
and I say this is actually not part of
our jobs so Mary and I didn't do this as
our jobs because we don't have funding
to do this right now so if we had
funding that would have allowed us to
respond to an emergency like this we
could have we were we were brought in by
atheists directly so we were a facin
ployees for the time period yeah so so
carbon sources are tremendously
important we have to make sure that they
bring carbon sources on it and right now
we're writing all of the stuff that
needed to be written in we have a very
large network of people from California
to to Virginia and there are a lot of
them are at land-grant universities and
we all sort of work on this together and
have meetings every couple years to talk
about mortality it's a fun time had by
all
anyway shavings we can use shavings and
they're often times on farms and they
used as bedding or ready for the for the
animals but they don't give you the
porosity that you really want you really
want chunky your material underneath the
chunkier the better because you need the
air to go to be pulled under the pile
from the bottom and it and the heat
pulls up through too many effect but we
really white like chunky your material
but we've got to work with what's on
hand and as you can see here this was
South Dakota there's nothing out there
there were no trees out there there was
you know that was just really hard to
find any carbon however so they had the
shaving so they had some shavings they
throw it in this gray stuff up here is
sunflower holes so the sunflower holes
actually held their strength and we had
good porosity around those so we could
use those as the base and the air would
be able to be pulled in from the bottom
of the pile so that we'd have fresh air
going through those piles the piles are
none of these piles are turned in the
beginning they're all static piles so we
want them to work by themselves we don't
want them and if we build them right
they will there's really no problem
we've been doing it for a very long time
so this gray stuff up here is then this
up here is a hot pile of manure that's
me on top of it I did walk up on top of
it so it's a pretty good-sized pile of
manure it was 160 degrees Fahrenheit so
we had good heat in that so we could use
that if we needed to for cover material
and for other stuff because it would
cook the birds and and they would
degrade in in somewhere around 15 16
days all different ages so you can see
they get really messy there hey they
have bad hair days when they are
starting to go down you can see over
here these guys their feathers are
sticking up and I only worked with
turkeys Mary only works with chickens as
a
but there was no rhyme or reason to that
so all different all different ages we
did bring the littlest so the babies we
brought in with with the adults with
some of the adults because they needed
to get access to that barn right away
and Efus allowed them to move them from
one barn to another barn yep you know
the barns in in California North Dakota
were beautiful they were sealed they
were contained they were good barnes
they were a lot better than what mary
had to deal with you could play football
inside if you needed to they were really
good sized barns in California it was
pretty ridiculous they had curtains so
they didn't have containment really so
they were just curtains over here or
would have been curtains over there but
they were open there was a a train track
right over here and they had a dinner
train that came by every Western they
did have to change their their process
because they were showing off
agriculture so they did shut the train
down for for a little while and they
didn't bring it by this area but it's
Modesto so you know you might as well be
looking at the agriculture I guess so
just a couple of things in these photos
well we could use was Bobcats we're
using the little Bobcats because the
ceilings are so low the waters are there
we had to dump all the waters they had
to be pulled up so that we didn't
destroy them there are misters up here
as well and I think that's it for that
one and this is a pile of feed so what
we did was we just train we just
directed all the feed right into the
barn so it could all be pushed together
and we could compost all of it because
all that stuff has to be sanitized
anything that's on the farm
sanitized one of the things that we
ended up having to do with this farm was
this piece these birds had died from the
avian influenza so we didn't have to use
any foam in here when we add phone to it
we're adding thousands of gallons of
water to it so we're working the two
different mediums and people had to get
used to that the fact that we this is
going to be different these piles
because we didn't have any moisture in
there any extra moisture in there we're
extremely dry so what we did was we put
the foggers on in those buildings and
added moisture to those piles and then
the temperatures went up pretty well
because they were so dry that they were
boisar was just too little for
composting actually occur but this is
what they should look like they should
be long piles we shouldn't have any you
know maybe some feathers but even
feathers we want everything covered so
everything has to be covered with carbon
and you have to have some kind of
material the manure could be used over
top other things could be used over
other carbon sources could be used over
top but we have to have everything well
covered back to South Dakota what we do
is we have to take that clumped manure
that's underneath the bedding and manure
that's underneath the the birds because
these are all on the floor there's no
cages there's nothing happening there so
we could just take the loader and go
down the middle row and clear that out
then we put carbon on top of that
because we have to have that air flowing
from the bottom so put the carbon on top
and then we took birds from the sides
and loaded those back on there was
controversy over whether we should be
making a mixed Center more like a
Twinkie so we would have carbon down
then we should mix them and then we
would put the carbon over top so there
was there still controversy over that we
prefer the layered method because we're
moving the birds less we're but not
creating a bio aerosol there when we're
working with them because we already
have to move them so they're already
make
with carbon they're already mixing with
the clump to the newer that's underneath
them so 60,000 turkeys here and that's
what we really should be looking like it
should look like toward the end I have
another picture that will show you
there's a little bit of material on the
floor but the floor should be pretty
clean even though they're dirt floors
most the buildings that I was in had
dirt floors but it should be a nice long
window and they were you know like I
said we could play football in those
buildings this is a clean floor so there
was one guy that was on the loader and
he just would go sailing around all the
polls and get it all off around the
poles he didn't have to do it manually
he was actually able to pick it up and
then after that a cleaning company would
come in and disinfect so when this barn
this barn was ready to be disinfected at
this point but that's because we moved
the baby birds out of this one and into
a different one temperatures we didn't
have any rules for releasing the piles
so when are we finished when have we
disinfected and I thought I always
thought in my head well we'd be testing
X amount of days in six days we'd be
testing those files to make sure that we
didn't have any virus left in the piles
that's not what was happening that's not
what the government was paying for so
what they were doing was and we do this
also we regulate by process in New York
State we regulate a lot by process so
the only rules that we have for
composting that one of the few rules
that we have for composting is the EPA
503 s and that's for bio solids it's for
for a human manure so we used those
because we knew that we could that we
could count on that because it had been
tested and also Virginia's had a lot of
low path AI that they've done some work
with but some of the air piles have SAT
for seven years because the farmers
don't have the confidence to say oh yeah
I'm going to flip spread that on my
on my farm and so there's a lot of that
what do we do composting should be
indoors as much as possible and outdoors
with his little movement as possible
should we leave the fans on I thought we
should cut a big filter and put it up on
the fan so that we weren't releasing so
that everything was was filtered before
it went out of the barns but that never
got any traction so we've just aerated
the bombs and and we spread the disease
I mean as as you can imagine 50 million
Birds it was spreading and in some
places in in Minnesota where Mary was in
Iowa we had massive spread in those
those states in North Dakota we only had
two incidents California we had the one
some other states we did have problems
with with disease transfer so
we had a new outbreak this year so we
have an outbreak in Indiana right now
and it's we talked about it being right
now because we it is existing all of the
birds are in piles but but it's only one
incident it seems like everything was
contained there was a high path pharm
and then it was surrounded by a couple
of low path farms so they've got that
contained and we haven't had any more
outbreaks at this point but we were
going into this in the winter and I said
you know we have this phone call every
Wednesday to talk about this stuff as
you can see we have kind of an exciting
life we talk about dead stuff anyway we
had to deal with cold weather wheezing
Birds frozen birds and all that kind of
stuff and it's different to be
composting to start composting at those
times a year so make sure making sure
that the Windrose were taller bigger
that we weren't putting frozen birds in
that we had good chunky material in
there if we have to put frozen birds in
the pile then we want to probably add
some of that hot manure that was out on
that that was composted and you know the
lesson one of the lesson learned lessons
learned here is that the farmers really
has to be composting they really have to
be composting their manure and their
routine mortality they call it the
routine mortality so that they have
practice number one and they have they
understand what materials work and what
materials don't work and if they had the
hot compost the hot manure compost on
farm then they can use that in a cold
situation we also can use other things
the leaf and yard waste compost
woodchips other things are hot in the
winter and we can bring those things in
birds can be incorporated into piles
frozen but they're not going to start
heating up until the outside temperature
the air temperature heats up so until it
warms up that's not going to happen one
time we put roadkill into a pile and it
was
arch and it was 5 degrees out that day
and the pile just froze they were frozen
beer and it just went down and this is
in a different situation the hot the
pile started warming up in May so you
know we used to keep ice in carbon to
keep it cold keep keep ice partially
frozen piles can heat up so if they've
already started one or they have some
heat in the pile it will ripple down the
pile so we've done that before and that
works pretty well so a lot of times
we're doing these in what we call the
lasagna method layers and will do them
will if we don't have all the birds at
one time we'll build a pile here that's
hot then we're adding some other birds
adding others in the winter through the
winter or cows or whatever and we're
adding those new winter and it heats up
compost covers could be used but then
they asked with that early on we're
considered experts so they asked us a
lot of these questions sometimes they
listen to us and sometimes they don't
we've had that experience but you know
at first I'm thinking that's just
another waste product we really don't
want to do that so we also can use those
if we have to to inflate to keep
moisture in and out but we also can do
that with a biofilter of carbon so we
can put wood chips over top of any of
these and accomplish the same thing so
we prefer to do that that way and in New
York we tend to regulation wise we tend
to do that when we have a problem when
managing the frozen piles the clock
starts when it gets to 110 or 36 c so
you know you can say okay we need this
much more time but that doesn't work I'm
going to talk yeah I'm going to talk
about that 05 must have gone out I have
a slide there I muscle it must have
dropped out anyway so what do we do
after we built these files we're taking
temperatures or somebody's taking
temperatures usually the APHIS vets or
somebody on site will be taking
temperatures after we leave we're there
to build the piles to make sure they are
working then somebody monitors because
there's no sense in us being there for
through that time period in 14 days and
this was being debated as we were
building piles in 14 days we decided
that the pile could be turned once and
at that point if we've met the
temperatures if we've gotten at that
point we were looking at 133 to 150 if
we had gotten that for ten days then ten
days in that time period in that pile
then we could turn that pile what we do
or three days I'm sorry three days then
add 14 days we could turn that pile and
what we would do is at that point we
would turn the pile outside because if
we've gotten those temperatures then
we've killed the virus
and then that could be moved so we've
moved that outdoors to finish composting
but at that point it was sanitized and
that's what we were trying to accomplish
at that point then they can go in and
take care of those buildings and
disinfect the buildings so in just in
general understand where the farm and
farmer are coming from take weather into
account assess which are the best
methods to dispose of the residuals all
the materials the dead stock the feed
the eggs water all that kind of stuff
develop guidance that's flexible because
every situations different so and every
carbon source is going to be different
and so we've got to be able to be
flexible enough to be able to
accommodate and get the job done are we
more prepared than before the outbreak
yeah we're definitely more prepared so
that's it yes and then we've discussed
it when you don't reach your
temperatures because there are about 12
of us that are out there were 12 of us
that from different parts of the country
and two of those were Canadians so they
were bringing them down to do some of
this yeah yeah yeah so basically the
rule that we were going by the guy
503 world for bio colors which basically
says in a static system three days at
131 x is expected and it's not stop at
131 a percent or of aesthetic is longer
you're right okay so it's a time window
Oh three days at 131 or yes Oh or higher
okay says that it is basically safe to
use in any situation okay that's why we
get Milwaukee's manure in our it loads
if we want to put it on our garden
Morgan I'm work yeah yeah so for this
but that's the only rule there ever was
do people just sort of use it as a guide
post now but if you look at all of the
literature on what is in activating the
AI virus it's 130 will fill it in 30 30
minutes yep okay and then lower
temperatures will take a little bit
longer but even if 35 as no no no much
so even it like no you're going to earn
my degrees Fahrenheit it will die it
will innovate inactivate within like a
week and a half the a is it's very not
stable it's like e.coli it's like you
know all those so we work however it can
persist in the fields in a pond or
whatever for a long period of time right
is water in the warm water better that's
all
the other until but in a contained
situation you know in that way you can
carry it on your shoes reallys is
probably more how it spreads then choose
entire tire everything the air results
because if in the chicken barn 5 next to
each other only two barns died that air
had to have been going in between and
those other three barns vids guys but so
what we finally got out you know it was
sort of a case-by-case basis and I don't
know if you have more questions usually
the answer and composting in Japan no
but if you took a case by case and wolf
its friends and temperatures that they
were reaching as long as they were
thermophilic so anywhere between 10 4
and 4 110 and 150 you were going to have
the right situations get rid of that to
inactivate that violence yes and we have
evidence that at 90 Fahrenheit we can in
that in that regards and I covered
ourselves without research sanitation of
the barns themselves only needed to be
like two days at 105 yep so why are we
treating the compost so differently and
making such a more stringent you know
basically we were more worried about the
bird decomposing and there not being any
flesh waste or anything like that left
when the turn or when we release the
public yeah you want a sitter so no lo
pap is always circulated in Birds almost
always and it causes some distress maybe
a couple of birds died because it's
ruffled feathers ish cuz rip causes loss
of egg production but in general and you
probably chicken farmer even a even one
who have them in their backyard probably
has low pass at most time but doesn't
necessarily notice anything the high
path is actually when you carry the
virus that's carried by wild birds into
a Lopez situation and the virus
mutate right okay and then it becomes
type ad and it almost always immediately
kills within you know two or three days
of getting the virus which is why we're
not so sure that it actually is airborne
right even though they say it is right
because those other cousins TTYL yeah
and if you're going in and but what the
rules are it's a reportable disease so
the rules are you have to kill them all
and get rid of it you don't want to tap
it and they look at you they look at a
whole radius also so they're looking at
a radius so farms in the area are also
check backyard flocks are checked three
miles and 10,000 via first of your own
you are not allowed to go out and test
right because you don't want to bring it
back your bird quick you know things
like that studies and I think that
actually in some of those situations
they put catchments out there for the by
the Panda and they were within like I
think it was like three feet bread
houses they found the virus is beyond
that they didn't right right and what
they may do as they they may just put a
so to speak a condom on the fan and
bring it down to the ground so it would
just take everything to the ground and
put it through a biofilter and then you
deal with it there instead of going
further out so it's either that or some
kind of filtration wild birds it's wild
birds well it could have more to do with
that who knows I don't think we know
that certainly could be hmm yeah but
this definitely spread through the
migration routes and luckily didn't hit
the eastern you can see why way each
time to buy with it
when the birds are flying over that yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu